hello my name is Sydney and I'm from
Nigeria another global shapers and with
this my first ever looked at my dental
devils and I just finished a
presentation and a session creates a new
models in education and my topic was in
bridging the gap and using technology
narrow areas and she's been so blown
away by the reception a little response
of the articles I've had a 777 Te'o's
volunteered to enter and give an hour of
their time everyone i have just so blown
away by I'm the amazing people in the
business 20 lips and supporting a young
Edwards and I'm a second learn I believe
my favorite dogs moment has just
happened actually because you as I
thought it was just a presentation and
it became more of a presentation and
people actually want to get involved and
actually help to improve the state of
education in rural areas and actually
give a call it opportunity in those
areas